[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
i think you have a beautiful smile first
of all thank you thanks
oh thank you
thank you
are you confident in your smile
hmm
yeah i'm pretty confident my smile i
think it's the the thing that disarms
the people the most
with me so i'm very confident in my
smile i think the thing that i'm
absolutely best at in the entire world
better than anybody else is making eye
contact with somebody and then smiling
at them and acknowledging their presence
so yeah i like my smile how does the
state of my smile impact how i feel
um so i will say i am more inclined to
smile very big when i have just brushed
my teeth i mean i feel like this is kind
of a materialistic answer but i'd say
that like when it's been a whole long
day and i haven't brushed my teeth since
the morning i definitely don't feel as
confident as like when i have freshly
brushed teeth
i didn't realize how much a smile could
really convey
because i never smiled in photos i was
always like scowling
or brooding looking and i just thought i
had an ugly smile i thought i had too
many my teeth were small i thought i had
gaps in my teeth then i just became more
comfortable in realizing like this is
the only smile i got so i'm just gonna
try and use it as much as i can
what do you think is the number one
chronic disease in america number one
chronic disease
depression probably mental health in
america or the world
america obesity probably cardiovascular
disease i would say i think that the
major chronic illness is heart disease
it's a good guess um it's actually tooth
decay
wow
okay did not see that one coming
way off i was
way off
tooth decay ow
is that shocking at all to hear that's
very shocking it's definitely a reality
that people
don't realize and probably overlook that
having access to good
proper dental care is a privilege and we
are very lucky those of us that are able
to just have things like toothpaste and
toothbrushes and
mouthwash and everything else
at our disposal
i mean man
if you think about it teeth are actually
decaying inside of your mouth that's a
disease for sure um people don't think
about it because i guess it's so
prevalent and nobody like
i can't say nobody cares but like i
don't just lack of awareness and you
know when you say the word ignorant it's
not in any derogative sense because i am
very ignorant i don't know how to change
my oil by myself i'm ignorant on how to
do so so
ignorance is the main reason why people
don't know that tooth decay is the most
prevalent disease i think there's
probably less access to affordable
dental care primary care comes first but
i think dental care is probably an
afterthought for a lot of people and i
never went to the dentist as a child
because just in my family you know we
didn't have a lot of money so it was
never a priority you know we didn't have
a lot of money but we were broke so if
that was the case for me i can't only
imagine what it's like for other
families that also didn't have that
bandwidth yeah it's something that i
hope that becomes more accessible to
more people as time goes on
maybe people are prioritizing things
more than dental care if they only have
like access to a certain amount of
resources maybe they are putting other
things first because they think that
that's more important or they're maybe
like putting it off that's what that's
what i would think
hey everyone dry here i think and i'm
sure we could all agree that all smiles
are beautiful but it's about how we
personally feel about our smile that
matters most and i'm not just talking
about how we feel about our smile
visually but also the health of our
smile and oral health tooth decay is the
number one chronic disease in america
and no one is immune every american
deserves a healthy smile but crest and
oral b know that the opportunities to
achieve it aren't always equal this year
crest and oral b are on a mission to
make great oral health a reality for
everyone in america and now i want you
all to come with me on a journey where
we'll get to see firsthand how crest and
oral b are helping make a positive
change by providing equitable access to
dental care education and products
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
i think you should start with my story
and that leads into what i do i grew up
in a low-income household and i had
amazing parents who care for me
but unfortunately they didn't know about
oral health or the importance of
prevention nobody ever taught them or
educated them about those things and so
then in turn they didn't educate me i
didn't know that i should be brushing or
that i should be flossing
or about nutritional counseling whether
i shouldn't eat all the candies
and so as a consequence i had a lot of
dental problems but because i was low
income i didn't have access to dental
care
[Music]
the first time i went to the dentist
i was probably around 13 years old
i was in such extreme pain that i
couldn't sleep
this pain
wouldn't go away
and my mom took me to a dentist
that dentist told my mom that i needed a
root canal and my parents couldn't
afford that
so instead my mom took me home and she
ground up clothes she would mix it with
water and i would stick it into the hole
in my tooth
and then i would try to sleep away the
pain
and while the home remedies helped some
it didn't help completely
so i just suffered through it
that memory is very vivid for me i i
remember the sun being bright i remember
the green and yellow sheets i know
that i was laying
at an angle is a very vivid memory for
me i'm pretty sure i had some sort of
perio treatment because i remember as a
young girl i would wake up in the
morning and there'd be blood on my
pillow
and it'd be dry blood on the corners of
my mouth and my mouth would be thick
but that stopped happening after i
received my dental care and i and i made
that connection
since then i've become a dental
hygienist the first one in my family to
graduate from college and i chose
another high team i've organized around
40 community outreach events and these
events are free to the community we do
free oral cancer screenings free
skilling
education because i truly believe in the
power of education
in offering people resources and letting
them know the resources available to
them so how has it been working with
crest and oral b how did you start
working with them
yeah christian ob has been amazing
through my story of access to care
they've supported me and in my entire
journey in
my vocal latinidad they've supported me
in being a minority and being strong and
outspoken
and i love that
but it's really made an impact in my
community they've provided me with free
products to give to my patients things
that i otherwise in our clinic doesn't
have resources to sometimes purchase
and so through them not only are they
supplying us with things which might
seem minimal for our patients who don't
have resources who don't have money it
makes an impact for them
because otherwise they wouldn't have
access to these things
we asked the children if they have a
toothbrush before we ask them if they're
brushing because a lot of children don't
have toothbrushes um i didn't have a
toothbrush growing up you know there was
probably things around but nothing
designated to me and we've learned that
in our communities it's
so easy to assume that everybody has the
same resources that we do and that's not
the reality
maybe it's our reality but it's not the
reality for the majority of the united
states we talk about
cavities being the number one chronic
disease what does that tell you that
tells you that there is a disparities
happening
and that's not just me and my
experiences that is there are statistics
and studies that show that you mentioned
earlier like when the last time your
your cheeks hurt my cheeks are right now
just talking about crescent about me
because i am really appreciative to them
and the support that they've given not
just me but my patients and
you know that as a big company like
crescendo b they don't have to do those
things
um and yet they do
and i don't see any other company out
there doing those things
yeah they took an interest in me and i
and i
don't necessarily feel like i bring that
much
value to them
but they definitely bring value to me
and to my patients
was i didn't want to cry
they choose to highlight
communities that are suffering
communities that do need advocacy
communities they're often overlooked
that says a lot to me
i think when we think about dental care
and how we take it for granted and we're
dealing with these children
and we think that their lives are so
simple their lives aren't simple their
lives are complicated we want to
provide them with education and
resources we're there to help them and
if we're not there to help them then we
don't need to be there
and i truly believe that i am not their
savior we are not their savior what
we're doing is important but it's one
thing that we're doing and so if we're
not there to do the good then we
shouldn't be there and i think that we
are
i don't know i just
i keep thinking back on how
i couldn't have imagined this for myself
being that child who was laying in a bed
in pain unable to sleep
and now to
be
partnering with christian oral b to
bring access to care to children like me
to
people like my parents
like my grandparents
and what a better life and i'm truly
grateful to creston rob that they are
supporting me in my mission and caring
for the community
and
turning a little girl suffering into a
mission
so that other children don't have to
suffer these same things
[Music]
you